en un vídeo anterior conocimos la idea
de la masa atómica promedio y comenzamos
a darnos cuenta de que podría ser una
forma muy útil de pensar en una masa a
nivel atómico oa nivel molecular pero lo
que haremos en este vídeo será asociar
esto a las masas de las muestras que en
realidad podríamos tener en un
laboratorio de química ya que es muy
poco probable que tratemos con un solo
átomo o unos pocos átomos es más
probable que tratemos con varios gramos
de una sustancia real entonces como
pasamos de las masas a escala atómica a
las masas de muestras que podemos
encontrar en un laboratorio de química o
en supongo que podríamos decir nuestra
escala del mundo bueno a la comunidad
química se le ocurrió una herramienta
útil dijeron está bien pensemos en un
elemento dado digamos litio sabemos que
su masa atómica promedio es 6.94
unidades de masa atómica unificadas por
átomo de litio qué pasaría si hubiera un
cierto número de átomos de litio por
cierta cantidad de átomos
tal que termináramos con 6 puntos 94
gramos de litio y este número de átomos
es 6.0 22 14 076 x 10 a la 23ava
potencia entonces si tenemos una muestra
con este número de átomos de litio esta
muestra tendrá una masa de 6.94 gramos
cualquiera que sea su masa atómica
promedio en términos de unidades de masa
atómica unificadas si tenemos ese número
de átomos tendremos una masa de ese
mismo número en términos de gramos ahora
se podrían preguntar hay un nombre para
este número y de hecho si hay un nombre
se llama número de avogadro nombrado en
honor del químico italiano de principios
del siglo 19 amadeo avogadro y en la
mayoría de los contextos porque
normalmente no vamos a trabajar con
datos con tantas cifras significativas
generalmente lo aproximamos como 6.0 22
por 10 a la 23ava potencia ahora hay
otra palabra que es muy útil recordar en
química y es
es la idea del mol ahora bien que es un
modo en química un mol significa que
tenemos esta cantidad de algo la palabra
mol fue utilizada por primera vez por el
químico alemán o william oswalt a
finales del siglo 19 y se le ocurrió la
palabra por su relación con la molécula
ahora qué significa eso bueno pensemos
en la palabra docena si digo que tengo
una docena de huevos cuántos huevos
tengo bueno si tengo una docena de
huevos
eso significa que tengo 12 huevos
entonces si digo que tengo un molde de
átomos de litio cuántos átomos de litio
tengo eso significa que tengo 6.0 22.40
76 x 10 a la 23 átomos de litio es
exactamente la misma idea solo que el
número de avogadro es mucho más grande
que el número de una docena entonces
usemos nuestros nuevos conocimientos
sobre el mol y el número de avogadro
para comenzar a hacer algunas cosas
útiles digamos que alguien se acerca y
nos dice hola
tengo una muestra de germanio de 15.4
miligramos cuantos átomos de germanio
hay pausa en el vídeo y traten de pensar
en esto permítanme hacer un poco de
espacio voy a quitar esta tabla
periódica de aquí muy bien entonces
comenzamos con 15.4 miligramos de
germanio el primer paso sería convertir
esto gramos de germanio y hacer un poco
de análisis dimensional podemos
simplemente multiplicar esto por cada
gramo de germanio que es equivalente a
1.000 miligramos de germanio
esencialmente al multiplicar por una
milésima o al dividir entre 1000 vamos a
obtener los gramos de germanio y podemos
ver eso en el análisis dimensional al
darnos cuenta de que esto se va a
cancelar con esto dejándonos solo los
gramos de germanio y ahora que tenemos
una expresión para gramos de germanio
podemos pensar en moles de germanio
entonces cómo hacemos eso bueno vamos a
multiplicar por alguna cantidad y en el
denominador vamos a querer gramos de
germanio para que el análisis
dimensional funcione y en el numerador
queremos que la nueva expresión estén
términos de moles de germanio entonces
un molde germanio es igual a cuántos
gramos de germanio bueno lo vemos aquí
mismo la masa molar del germanio es 72
puntos 63 gramos por mol entonces por
cada mol tenemos 72 puntos 63 gramos de
germanio y podemos ver que las unidades
funcionan estos gramos de germanio se
van a cancelar con los gramos de
germanio dejando no solamente con moles
de germanio en una práctica de química
real descubrir los moles de una
sustancia en realidad podría ser lo más
útil pero si queremos calcular los
átomos reales de germanio con los que
estamos tratando simplemente
multiplicaremos por el número de átomos
que tiene por mol y esto se cumplirá
para cualquier elemento por cada mol
habrá el número de avogadro de átomos
vamos a aproximar esto como 6.0 22 por
10 a la 23 átomos de germanio por cada
molde germanio y sólo para repasar lo
que acabamos de hacer tenemos miligramos
de germanio multiplicamos estos dos
juntos y tendremos gramos de germanio
tiene sentido porque básicamente estamos
dividiendo entre 1000 si multiplicamos
los gramos de germanio por moles por
gramo que es solamente el recíproco de
esta masa molar que tenemos aquí y para
asegurarnos de que esto tiene sentido
nos aseguramos de que las unidades
funcionan bien con el análisis
dimensional esto justo aquí nos dice los
moles de germanio y luego si tomamos los
moles y los multiplicamos por el número
de avogadro sabremos cuántos átomos de
germanio hay esto tiene sentido porque
si les dijera que tengo una cierta
cantidad de docenas de huevos y quisiera
saber cuántos huevos tengo multiplicaría
esto por 12 así que toda esta expresión
es el número de átomos de germanio
sacamos la calculadora y tenemos 15.4
miligramos si queremos saber cuántos
gramos tenemos dividimos esto entre 1000
esto es lo que nos dice nuestro análisis
dimensional lo que también tiene sentido
lógico lo dividimos entre 1000 entonces
esta es la cantidad de gramos que
tenemos y luego si queremos saber
cuántos moles son
a hacer una pequeña fracción de un mal
porque un moles 72.73 gramos por mol y
tenemos una fracción de gramo que es
mucho menor a 72 puntos 63 gramos
entonces de nuestro análisis para
calcular la cantidad de moles ahora
vamos a dividir entre 72 puntos 63 es
igual a este es el número de moles de
germanio que tenemos y si queremos
averiguar la cantidad de átomos de
germanio luego multiplicaremos eso por
el número de avogadro esto por 6.0 22
por 10 a la 23 y este botón
significa multiplicado por 10 a la 23 es
así como lo hacemos en una calculadora y
esto nos da la cantidad de átomos y
veamos para obtener nuestras cifras
significativas aquí las cifras
significativas de todas las cosas que
multiplicamos vemos que teníamos cuatro
cifras significativas aquí cuatro cifras
significativas aquí pero sólo tuvimos
tres por aquí entonces voy a redondear a
tres cifras significativas
dónde vamos a 1.28 por 10 a la 20 átomos
tenemos aproximadamente 1.28 por 10 a la
20 átomos de germanio que es mucho